FROM D.C. HAVE A GUIDE.
GOOD NIGHT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT TODAY AS YOU HEARD
AGREES WITH.
AN AWFUL LOT OF IMMIGRANTS
COME FROM THIS COUNTRY FROM
PLACES NOT VERY NICE.
THEY ARE DANGEROUS, DIRTY,
CORRUPT AND POOR AND THAT'S
THE MAIN REASON THOSE
IMMIGRANTS ARE TRYING TO
COME HERE AND YOU WOULD,
TOO, IF YOU LIVE THERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED WHY
AMERICA DOESN'T RECEIVE
IMMIGRANTS FOR FROM PLACES
YOU WANT TO VISIT ON
VACATION WHY NOT NORWAY
WHICH BY THE U.N.'S MEASURES
IS THE MOST DEVELOPED AND
RICHEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
WHILE SAYING THIS TRUMP USED
EXLETTIVE NOT SURPRISING
EITHER BECAUSE HE USES THEM
ALL THE TIME AND WAS
EVERYONE IN NEW YORK AND
L.A. CONSIDERED THIS A
MAJOR, MAJOR EVENT.
WHY IS THAT?
TO FIND OUT, WE ARE JOINED
BY JOSE, COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR BARACK OBAMA'S
2012 CAMPAIGN AND HE JOINS
US IN STUDIO.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE YOU CAN
IMMIGRANTS FROM AND WE ARE
HAVING THAT DEBATE.
WHAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT THE
EXPLOSION THIS AFTERNOON IS
THE DISHONESTY IN IT.
I WILL GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE.
JOAN WALSH ON CNN AN ANNUAL
UNDERSTAND NORWAY.
SHE SAID WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE I CAN'T SAY.
NOW, THAT'S LYING.
IF WE HAVE GOTTEN TO THE
POINT WHERE WE ALL HAVE TO
PRETEND EVERY COUNTRY IS AS
EXACTLY AS NICE AS EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY THEN WE ARE
BEING DISHONEST.
>> BASICALLY THEY ARE
INSULT ON THE PEOPLE COME
FROM THESE COUNTRIES MAKING
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
EL SALVADOR AND HAITI WHERE
BETWEEN THESE COUNTRIES WE
ARE TALKING PEOPLE FROM
THOSE COUNTRIES THEY ARE
FULL CONTRIBUTION TO THE
ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: IT'S A
COMPLICATED PICTURE BUT I
AGREE WITH YOU IF YOU ARE
SAYING THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMING FROM THOSE COUNTRIES
ARE GOOD PEOPLE OF COURSE I
COMPLETELY AGREE.
THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE NOT
HAITI, FOR EXAMPLE, OR EL
SALVADOR, I HAVE BEEN TO
BOTH OF THEM.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING THEM TO COME HERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
SIN IS YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO POINT OUT OTHER COUNTRIES
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM.
>> THERE IS DEFINITELY AN
ISSUE HERE BECAUSE WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE THE PRESIDENT
IS ARTICULATING THE SAME
VISION WE SAW IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
WHEN THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: BE RATIONALE
HERE.
>> IT LOOKS THE SAME.
>> Tucker: SLOW DOWN, IF YOU
WERE TO HAVE.
>> WHOLE MASSES ON THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY THAT WE
WITH ME HERE, OKAY?
THE PRESIDENT FROM WHAT WE
KNOW AND MAYBE OTHER THINGS
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
WHAT WE KNOW THESE COUNTRIES
ARE CRUMMY PLACES, HOLES,
WHATEVER, HE USED PROFANITY
THE PEOPLE WHO LEFT THOSE
ROAD TRAINS OR ANY A WHEEL
WELL, THEY WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT WHY THE OUTRAGE?
IS IT YOU HAVE TO LIE AND
PRETEND AS JOAN WALSH DOES I
DON'T KNOW I WOULD LIVE IN
NORWAY OR HAITI LIKE WE HAVE
GOTTEN TO A PLACE WHERE
NOBODY CAN BE HONEST ABOUT
ANYTHING.
DO YOU SEE THE POINT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT S. THAT DO WE
APPLY THE SAME METRIC TO
COUNTRIES THAT ARE NOT DOING
TOO WELL RIGHT NOW?
CRIME MEASURES?
>> WE SEEM TO BE APPLYING
THIS ONLY TO COUNTRIES WHERE
THERE ARE BROWN PEOPLE SUCH
SAID YESTERDAY WHICH AGAIN
TIES BACK TO THE SOCIAL
ENGINEERING THAT TRYING TO.
NORWAY ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED NATIONS, THE MOST
DEVELOPED COUNTRY DRY IN THE
WORLD.
SOVEREIGN WEALTH AND BIGGEST
IN THE WORLD BECAUSE OF THE
OIL DISCOVERIES OFFSHORE
THERE AS YOU KNOW.
RICHEST PLACE IN THE WORLD,
OKAY?
HAITI IS THE POOREST PLACE
IN THE HEMISPHERE AND HAS
BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
LEGALLY BECAUSE HAITI IS SO
BAD WE DON'T THINK THEY
SHOULD HAVE TO RETURN.
IF YOU SAY NORWAY IS A
BETTER PLACE TO LIVE AND
YOU ARE JUMPING UP AND DOWN
AND SAYING YOU CAN'T SAY
WANT TO LIVE IN TRUMP'S
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE MAKING
THE POINT.
>> ABOUT VALUES.
ATTACHING THIS LABEL FROM
PEOPLE WHO COME FROM
PREDOMINANTLY BROWN
COUNTRIES THAT IS A PROBLEM.
S ARE BEING MADE.
WHEN YOU TAKE AWAY LEGAL
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION?
>> CONTRIBUTING TO THIS
COUNTRY THEN, ARE YOU USING
THE STATUTE OR ARE YOU USING
PREJUDICE TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS?
>> Tucker: PREJUDICE,
RACISM.
TERMS, FINAL.
NORWAY, HAITI.
>> Tucker: ONE IS THE
RICHEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
AND THE OTHER IS ONE OF THE
POOREST COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
YOU THINK THAT'S IMMORAL TO
POINT IT OUT A STATEMENT OF
VALUES.
IF HAITI ISN'T SUCH A BAD
PLACE, WHY DON'T WE SAY TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
TEMPORARILY, IN REFUGE FROM
IT'S NOT GREAT.
ACTUALLY, IT'S EVERYTHING
THE PRESIDENT SAID IT WAS.
IT'S NOT AN ATTACK ON
HAITIANS, IT'S AN
IF YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY THAT
OUT LOUD WITHOUT BEING
CALLED A RACIST BY PEOPLE
LIKE YOU AND THE MORONS AT
MSNBC.
>> YOU ARE CALLING ME A
MORON.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT CALLING
YOU A MORON.
>> TALKING ABOUT A PREDOM
PREDOMINANTLY WHITE COUNTRY
AND PREDOMINANTLY AFRICAN
COUNTRY OR PEOPLE OF AFRICAN
DISSENT.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY THAT?
HOW ABOUT CRIME MEASURES?
CORRUPTION?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> THE PRESIDENT JUST SAID A
FEW WEEKS AGO THAT EVERYBODY
IN HAITI HAS AIDS AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY HE
WANTED TO CANCEL IT PS EVEN
THOUGH PEOPLE ARE HERE AND
HAVE BEEN VETTED TIME AND
>> YOU DO KNOW.
COMING FROM THE LEADER OF
MYSELF HERE AGAIN I THINK
THERE ARE PLENTY OF GREAT
PEOPLE FROM HATE I DON'T.
>> DO YOU KNOW ANY?
>> Tucker: I HAVE MET A TON
A LOT OF THEM HAVE DONE
WELL.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN PEOPLE
FROM POOR COUNTRIES NOT A
MEASURE OF MORAL STATURE
WHEN YOU COME FROM A POOR
COUNTRY MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
BE POOR WHEN YOU ARE HERE.
THERE IS A LOT OF POVERTY
ALREADY HERE IF IN CASE YOU
REAL QUESTION HOW MUCH.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN'T LOOK AT
ME AND SAY THAT'S RACIST.
I HAVE THE NUMBERS WHERE
IMMIGRANTS COME FROM.
LAST YEAR WE HAD 23,000
IMMIGRANTS FROM EL SALVADOR.
GREAT PEOPLE.
WE HAD 404 FROM NORWAY.
COUNTRIES AND IT'S AN HONEST
QUESTION.
NOT A RACIAL ONE.
WHAT EFFECT DOES THAT HAVE
ON THE POT OF RATE IN THIS
COUNTRY?
>> CAN I TELL YOU THAT WHILE
THAT YOU FOLLOW THE BASIC
LAWS OF ECONOMIC.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE PAYING TAX
SYSTEM LIKE THE 23,000
NUMBER THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
>> Tucker: FROM EL SALVADOR.
>> OR 200,000 WHO HAVE TPS
AND THE STATUS WAS JUST
REVOKED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST WEEK,
YOU ARE TAKING THAT
THEY ARE BUYING GAS.
THEY ARE BUYING CLOTHES.
THEY ARE GOING TO
SUPERMARKETS AND THEY ARE
STIMULATING LOCAL AND
NATIONAL ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN GENERALIZATIONS
AND, AGAIN, I ACTUALLY GHIR.
>>
ADMIRE.
THESE ARE THE RATES OF
WELFARE USE BY COUNTRY.
THESE ARE FAMILIES THAT ARE
USING AT LEAST ONE WELFARE
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS IT'S
73%.
THE NETWORK.
ECONOMIC COST IN BRINGING
PEOPLE OVER WHO ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GO ON PUBLIC
SERVICES AND WHO ARE POORER.
THAT'S NOT A RACIAL ATTACK.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC OBSERVATION
IN A COUNTRY THAT HAS A TON
OF POOR PEOPLE ALREADY AND
HAVE YOU NO ANSWER FOR THAT
OTHER THAN OH IT'S
SOCIAL ENGINEERING.
THE WHOLE WORRY HERE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TO DO
AWAY WITH FAMILY BASED
MIGRATION.
FAMILY MIGRATION WHAT THEY
CONSIDER IS LEADING TO THE
BROWNING OF AMERICA.
I'M THROWING ACTUAL
STATISTICS AT YOU AND YOU
ARE GETTING BACK TO THE
BROWN BLACK WHITE THING.
>> I GAVE YOU NUMBER IMPACT
PEOPLE FROM EL SALVADOR AND
PEOPLE FROM HAITI RIGHT NOW.
LIKELY TO GO ON WELFARE AND
MAKE LESS, DOESN'T MEAN THEY
ARE BAD PEOPLE BUT THE COST
OF HAVING THEM HERE IS
HIGHER THAN PEOPLE FROM
OTHER REGIONS.
THAT ACTUALLY SAY IMMIGRANTS
ARE NO MORE LIKELY TO GO ON
RECORD.
>> Tucker: I WOULD BE
FASCINATED TO SEE THAT STUDY
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T EXIST.
>> IT DOES EXIST.
>> Tucker: RATE OF AMERICAN
FAMILIES 1%.
THAT'S HIGHER THAN
IMMIGRANTS FROM SOUTH ASIA.
PREPONDERANCE OF IMMIGRANTS
ARE COMING FROM SOUTH
AFRICA.
THOSE RATES ARE HIGH.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT BUT YOU
SAY IT'S RACIST.
>> CAN I TELL YOU SOMETHING,
HAVE YOU HEARD OF THE FIVE
YEAR BAR?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE FIVE YEAR BAR IS.
>> A FIVE YEAR BAR SALAH
THAT CONGRESS PASSED THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW AN IMMIGRANT
ONCE THEY REGULAR RISE THEIR
STATUS TO ACCESS WELFARE.
HOW IS IT THAT YOU ARE
COMING UP FROM THOSE NUMBERS
PREVENTS PEOPLE UNLESS YOU
ARE CONSIDERING WHEN YOU GET
A SCHOLARSHIP FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS ACTUALLY AN
INVESTMENT INTO THE COUNTRY.
FACTORING ON WELFARE THAT'S
REALLY PROBLEMATIC.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO ABOUT HALF OF ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> FIVE YEAR BAR IN THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: LET ME SPEAK TO
THE REALITY RATHER THAN THE
LAW.
>> THE LAW IS REALITY BY THE
WAY.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY THE LAW
IS NOT REALITY.
IF THE LAW WAS REALITY WE
WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION.
>> I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS MEDICARE BECAUSE OF
FIVE YEAR BAR.
>> Tucker: ABOUT HALF OF ALL
IMMIGRANTS FROM EL SALVADOR
RIGHT NOW ARE LIVING AT OR
BELOW THE POVERTY LINE.
NOT BAD PEOPLE.
NOT AN ATTACK ON THEM.
NOT TRUE FROM IMMIGRANTS
FROM OTHER REGIONS OF THE
WORLD.
WHY IS IT IMMORAL FOR
AMERICANS TO MAKE THE CAN A
CALCULATION WHAT MAKES US
MORE PROSPEROUS.
>> MOST PEOPLE LIVING BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
>> IN THE FULL-TIME ECONOMY.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
REGULARIZED THROUGH A
PROGRAM LIKE TPS.
THERE STUDIES BY
CONSTRUCTION AROUND THE
ARE WELL-TRAINED AND
PRODUCING JOBS FOR OTHER
PEOPLE AND GENERATING --
>> Tucker: THERE ARE PLENTY
OF IMMIGRANTS WELL TRAINED.
>> CONTRIBUTING TO
280 BILLION TO THE G.D.P. OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THESE NUMBERS.
>> OH, YES I DO.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
THEORETICAL QUESTION THEN.
CATO INSTITUTE.
AND FORBES MAGAZINE WHICH
I'M SURE YOU CONSIDER THAT A
LEFTIST PUBLICATION.
>> Tucker: LET'S GET TO A
PHILOSOPHICAL QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK IT'S FAIR FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO LIVE
HERE TO DECIDE WHO COMES ON
THE BASIS OF WHO WILL
>> IN 1965, WE CHANGED THE
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY TO BE
CLOSER TO FAMILY BASED
MIGRATION BECAUSE.
>> Tucker: PLEASE ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
>> WE WERE USING QUOTAS.
>> Tucker: WE ARE USING
QUOTE AS IT NOW.
>> 8 TO 1 WANT DREAMERS TO
DREAMERS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU CAN'T
FILIBUSTER.
DO YOU THINK, AT LEAST
THEORETICALLY ALLOWED FOR --
HOLD ON LET ME FINISH.
LET'S IF I
LET'S FF I
LET'S FIGI
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHO IS MOST
LIKELY TO ADD TO OUR
COUNTRY?
WHO IS MOST LIKELY TO
ASSIMILATE?
IS THAT OKAY OR RACIST LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE I HAVE
BROUGHT UP?
IS THAT OKAY TO BRING UP
THAT QUESTION?
>> IMMIGRANTS DO ASSIMILATE.
>> Tucker: IS IT FAIR TORE
AMERICANS TO ASK THAT
QUESTION?
WHAT'S GOOD FOR US?
ARE WE ALLOWED TO ASK THAT
QUESTION OR WHO IS RACIST?
>> WHO IS WE WHEN WE SAY
AMERICANS?
RIGHT NOW 86.
MAJORITY OF THE ELECTORATE?
>> THE LATEST POLL THAT CAME
OUT TODAY SAYS THAT 80% OF
AMERICANS WANT DREAMERS TO
ASSIMILATE.
INCLUDING TWO THIRDS OF
APPLES AND ORANGES.
>> NO WE ARE NOT.
WE ARE ARGUING ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: DOES A COUNTRY
HAVE A RIGHT TO DECIDE WHO
COMES IN AND WHO DOESN'T
COME IN?
>> MOST AMERICANS WANT
IMMIGRATION REFORM IN 2013
BY EVERY POLL.
>> Tucker: YOU WON'T ANSWER
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T.
>> BY EVERY POLL AND YOU
GUYS PASSED THAT IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU GUYS WANT
TO FIX THE SYSTEM.